the perfect shape of the keys or I can
just feel my way around to type without
even looking down the feedback as my
thumbs strike the pad while making no
typos my name is Johanna and I have a
problem I love phones with physical
keyboards some people say I'm living in
the past at the time for physical
keyboards is over that Blackberry is
barely hanging on by a thread and all
these other companies that once made
phones with physical keyboards are just
making touchscreen phones but there's
hope no the answer isn't buying a new
BlackBerry instead there are two new
iPhone keyboard cases for people like me
you prefer real keys there's this one
for $60 and this one for $100 and these
could be the solution to all my problems
except they have their own problems
first I checked out the typo keyboard
$100 case is thin and resembles of
blackberry keyboard in fact it looks so
much like one that blackberry is taking
typos maker to court seriously it looks
exactly like a blackberry the company
still says it plans to ship this month
though typing on the keys feels a lot
like typing on a blackberry tear the
case via bluetooth with the iPhone and
you're off to the races I've been able
to type about 57 words per minute that's
double what I can type per minute on the
iPhone software keyboard but it isn't
perfect the case covers up the iPhones
home button replacing it with a home key
in the lower right hand corner it's a
big problem if you use the iPhone 5s
fingerprint sensor the case is also very
plasticky and keys can make this
annoying sound when you type sorry both
father and I had other issues with the
typo
you can't use the iPhones autocorrect
feature the case makes the phone bottom
heavy and you have to charge the case
via microUSB it isn't powered by the
phone itself so Bluetooth has some
downsides and that's why instead the spy
keyboard case does something
little bit different they take the
physical keyboard and put it right on
top of Apple software keyboard as you
press these keys it hits the software
keys when you don't need the keyboard
you can flip it out of the way the
problem with that is that I'm constantly
flipping it out of the way want to
unlock the phone
flip want to watch a video flip read an
article flip again and I'd say that
would be worth it but the keyboard isn't
very good
the keys are too close together and you
have to press harder than you should
this bike actually makes me type worse
than I do on my iPhones on-screen
keyboard both the typos in this bike are
only out for the iPhone so what's an
android piper supposed to do there are
some very clunky Bluetooth keyboards but
there are easier ways to ease into
touchscreen typing with Android first
there is some assistance with wider
screen phones like the 5-inch Galaxy s4
there's just more screen real estate
with those I can type closer to 35 words
per minute then there are options like
swipe where you draw a line from letter
to letter to build a word and then rely
on its auto prediction to speed things
up I average closer to 32 words per
minute with swipe though I have to look
down the screen a lot I was fastest on a
touchscreen with Swift key at 40 words
per minute it has a great layout and
prediction people say I'll come around
to typing on touchscreen keyboards it
looks like I'll have to physical
keyboards seem to get in the way of the
touchscreen experience still for now the
type o keyboard isn't a bad crutch for
someone like me who just has this
obsession with real keys maybe one day
I'll get that perfect case maybe one day